this is the Joo underground podcast
number 93 sitting here with Echo
Charles this is me Joo willink and we're
going to talk about the Eagles versus
the Rattlers you know anything about
this no you don't this was the
culmination of an experiment that was a
psychological and a sociological
experiment that was conducted in the
late 1950s early 1960s a guy named mfer
Sharif he was a Turkish American social
psychologist just he was alive from 1906
to 1988 and back in the day you could do
some wild stuff with experiments right
yeah and actually I don't know we can
discuss this one wasn't I actually think
this one was kind of
okay I might be wrong but and also it's
an experiment that you can see just play
out all the time so they took 22
11-year-old
boys and
they brought brought them to a camp they
were all white kids with similar middle
class backgrounds so they're pretty
similar kids 22 of them they split them
into two different
teams at first they didn't even know
each other they didn't they weren't
together at
first and they spent a few days just
doing activity separate they didn't know
the other team existed so they just show
up at a camp and they have 11 guys total
on a
team and they start doing like hiking
together there swimming they're playing
games like fun not competitive against
each other games but like oh let's try
and do this let's swim over there let's
go for hike just kind of doing things
together and they just did these
Cooperative events as a team and they
started to like form bonds and become
friends this was like a four or five day
period and they ended up each of them
independently coming up with names for
their little team one of them called
themselves the Eagles the other ones
called themselves the ra the
Rattlers and then they took they made
shirts they made Flags they like got
kind of fired up they were part of this
crew and then they took the two groups
and they brought them together and they
started to put them in
competitive games and
situations and they started to develop a
prejudice against each other m
and they would do things they would like
have a picnic they would they they would
do a combined picnic but one of the
teams they would set it up so one of the
teams would get there early and eat all
the food from the other team and then
that kind of escalated the Eagles
eventually burned the Rattler's flag the
Rattlers invaded the Eagles cabins and
stole their gear and vandalized their
stuff and eventually the researchers had
to fiz physically separate the two
groups then they put him into a
two-day um cooling off period where they
just got to relax they didn't they
didn't create any more hostilities
between them and then they had
them during that time write words to
describe what the other group was like
and you can imagine you know the other
group is conniving and you know evil and
all that kind of stuff and my group is
good and we're upstanding
and then what they did was they brought
them
together and now they had them work and
this was really interesting to me they
had them work
on projects together where in order to
be successful they had to work together
and it was mutually beneficial to both
teams and when they did
that that they found was the best way to
unify both groups together
and unify both groups together and
reduce
conflict a superordinate goal this is
interesting this is what I've been
calling for the last two years I think
is climbing the ladder of alignment what
do we actually what are we aligned
on
and the other interesting thing is when
they just had them hang out together for
instance they'd say hey you guys are
going to watch movie together tonight or
you're going to come and eat together
tonight it didn't help didn't help unify
the teams at all they would still they'd
argue about what movie to watch they'd
argue about like how much food but as
soon as they had a superordinate
goal to that they needed to work
together on that's what bonded the
group
so this out of this came the realistic
group conflict theory it's basically
that groups will get get competitive
over resources all that stuff is real
obvious this is one of those things
where like you know you think to
yourself yeah no kidding you had to do
an experiment even this whole thing oh
you had to do an experiment to figure
this out this is so obvious this is like
every group of kids that hangs out
together and there's another group of
kids at the other end of the street and
they hang out together and if there's
scarce resources they're going to fight
that's the way it is
yeah and I just thought it was an
interesting uh real clear example of the
fact that we're tribal animals yeah and
if you're not paying attention you can
become part of a tribe you don't even
recognize that you're part of this tribe
and you start thinking things that you
have no actual reason for thinking but
you're thinking them and if you're not
paying attention that can happen yeah
so my overall advice is pay attention
you don't want to be an eagle you don't
want to be a rattler they they have no
fundamental reason for this
anger and prejudice against each other
but then it escalates from little things
you know it's just a little thing oh you
ate some of our cake oh well then we're
going to take your cake and we're going
to smash it okay then we're going to
burn your flag okay we're going to raid
your cabins you let that go if the
researchers let that go who knows man
maybe someone's getting killed yeah you
know what I'm say that's basically what
gangs do yeah that
is
so be careful yeah big time and
obviously you know you explaining that
whole thing you can think of all the
different examples varying levels of it
where the first one comes to mind
obviously is the sports fans right how
they always get into the fights and you
know and the thing 100% based on a
sports team that they have probably
never played for never going to play for
probably don't even know personally you
know they don't have a personal
relationship with not one single member
of the whole company not even just the
team like no nothing never met them in
real life whatever and they're still
that unified over the fact that they
play in that City you
know and you're right it stems from like
that one commonality right that one like
uh uh common interest in whatever way
and then from there it just grows almost
like you forget the common interest you
just have that feeling and then you just
move forward almost automatically in a
way so it's like okay someone who
opposes the San Diego Chargers I know
they're not in San Diego anymore but my
psychological example is San Diego
Chargers so one who opposes the San
Diego charges they're kind of like the
enemy in this little seed in my mind you
know so anything that kind of confirms
that just exacerbates it more and more
and more same thing about your
presidential candidate of choice you
know oh that freaking Trump supporter or
that whatever supporter you know kind of
a thing and I'm not that so they're on
the other team and then freaking just
hostility from there hostility you know
when JP was on the podcast and we were
talking about getting a platoon to break
when we were running training
all you have to do is create some little
bit of little kernel of animosity
between the troops and they just
self-destruct bro and that's what's
going on that's what's going on in
America you know it's like oh you what
you should be thinking is you should be
thinking hey if I'm mad at Ekko Because
he believes this thing that's actually
no matter where I'm at that's bad for
that's bad for everybody it's bad for
America yeah if I'm mad at you because
you have a different political belief
than me and instead of me going oh yeah
well you know it's America you can he
can support his ideas and I'll support
my ideas and we'll see which one goes
goes further and I'll continue to work
against what he's think but I'm not mad
at him yeah but the minute I'm like no I
actually hate Ekko yeah now cu the that
Colonel grows man yeah it grows big time
and now actually I don't just hate the
fact that you don't like this one
political thing that I like now I hate
everything about you yeah now I hate
every political belief you have it's
been weird to watch the way things have
flipped upside down in the political
Spectrum where like for instance the the
uh Democrats pretty much being like Pro
big Pharma now is kind of crazy yeah and
and them bring basically proar in
Ukraine when you know when you would
traditionally think of where who's
supporting the big companies oh it's the
Republicans yeah or who's supporting War
oh it's the Republicans now you have a
literal flip of that yeah yep and it
doesn't surprise me given this one thing
that I witnessed from some insiders so
I'm not going to name nobody's name
but so this one Insider had a meeting
with someone another Insider MH and this
meeting had another person involved in
it who
said um we're going to block this and it
was was like some Bill or some thing
right some we're going to block this
bill even though it's a good bill and in
fact we all talked about passing this
bill like two years ago but since they
kind of formulated it in U or or
finalized it or whatever I don't know
the terms but since they basically uh uh
announced it first like it's their bill
they want to block it even though it's
like literally the one that they had you
know so it's a good bill everyone agrees
on it but since they did it it was the
other political side since they're
bringing it out we're going to block it
that's how deep it goes like the whole
country at risk by the way fre pathetic
oh yeah so that kind of stuff
do freak idiots that's what they are
they're a bunch of freaking idiots
they're donkeys I've been I've mentioned
this a few
times that is a little excerpt of what
we are doing on the Joo underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen go to Joo underground.com and
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us strengthen this
Legion of Troopers that are in the game
with us so thank you it's Joo
underground.com it costs
$818 cents a month and if you can't
afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance atj
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground